in this video we'll be ranking the top
20 characters in demon slayer we will
start with the weakest upper moon daki
and by the end of the video we'll be
covering some of the most powerful
characters daki is a very powerful demon
that is more than 100 years old she
along with her brother is the main
antagonist in the entertainment district
arc daki has been personally
acknowledged by muzan himself as being a
special demon it's been noted that daki
was able to kill and eat seven hashidas
in the past further exemplifying her
strength and if you think that's crazy
just remember that there are 19 more
characters stronger than her her flesh
detachment in the form of a sentient
obisash was strong enough to hold off
the combined efforts of zenitsu inosuke
makio and suma the former two being
seasoned demon slayers while the latter
two being shinobis even a weaker form of
daki was already too much for tanjiro
who had begun to actively use the
hinokami kagura in combat after her obi
spread across the entire city returns to
her daki's power dramatically increases
so much though that her speed in this
form was incomparable from before in
this form her sashies also become more
durable allowing them to slice nezuko's
body in half and destroy buildings with
ease furthermore once gyutaro's eye is
implanted in her daki's power is
amplified once again giving her improved
speed and reflexes that can outclass the
likes of zenitsu's thunderclap and flash
technique this also allows daki to
coordinate her attacks with her brother
drastically increasing their offensive
output even though she held the lowest
number for the upper ranked demons she
showed immense power proving just how
strong the upper moons are let's
continue this list with one of the fan
favorites number 19 inosuke hashibita we
first saw him at suzumi mansion and he
quickly became a very important part of
the show inosuke is a very skilled and
talented swordsman as he was able to
learn total concentration breathing on
his own and developed his very own
breathing style known as beast breathing
based on his own instincts and
upbringing in the mountains by wild
boars he passed final selection and
became a demon slayer without any formal
training inosuke is more than capable of
hunting and slaying demons on his own as
he easily killed the horned demon in a
tsuzumi mansion without any trouble he
has shown on multiple occasions to be
able to hold his own and contribute in
fights against upper ranked demons
including upper rank 6 gyutaro and daki
as well as the much stronger upper rank
2 doma he is also incredibly gifted
possessing inhuman senses and superhuman
flexibility as well as natural aptitude
in combat most impressively inosuke was
able to fend off the demon king muzan
along with his fellow comrades showing
the skill that is equal to a hashida
number 18 zenitsu agatsuma even though
it was never officially stated that
zenitsu is stronger than inosuke we
rated him higher on the list due to the
massive potential of his breathing style
from the beginning zenitsu comes off as
a very talented demon slayer though he
denies this zenitsu's true strength
awakens when he is asleep as that's when
his nerves that normally keep him from
accessing his true strength give out
making him more sagacious calm and
precise in combat which allowed him to
instantly decapitate the tongue demon
and defeat the spider demon by himself
he was later able to defend three entire
train carts that were being under attack
by enmu a few months after that he was
able to stand on equal grounds with an
awakened daki with the assistance of
inosuke and later managed to blitz her
with thunderclap and flash his signature
ability as further credence to his
strength zenitsu was able to advance to
the highest point of the hashida
training however his true strength seems
to manifest when zenitsu can fight while
awake as he managed to match the new
upper rank six kaigaku in power by
himself and later decapitated him using
his own seventh form flaming thunder god
by the end of the series zenit2's
strength more than likely matched that
of the hashida the first hashida on our
list is obanai iguro coming in on the
17th spot as a hashida of the demon
slayer core obanai is a very powerful
and skilled swordsman it was revealed
that he was more or less blind in his
right eye meaning he ascended to the
highest rank in the demon slayer core
with one functioning eye this combined
with his small physique and subpar
physical strength makes it especially
impressive that obani managed to attain
hashida's status during the infinity
castle arc obanai was able to quickly
decapitate numerous demons and hold back
the newly appointed upper rank 4 nakime
when engaging in battle with the demon
king obani was able to land a lot of
hits on him slashing off limbs and
nearly beheading him over the course of
the battle after he and the rest of the
demon slayers were heavily injured by
muzan's attack obanai was the first one
to regain consciousness and aid tanjido
despite having his eyes clawed out
during the earlier attack since muzan
was severely weakened by the drugs in
his system obani and tanjido managed to
fend off and push the demon king into a
corner by themselves displaying
incredible stamina and endurance despite
getting directly hit by muzan's
shockwave technique he still took a hit
for tanjido when muzan was able to bite
his head off even though obanite lost
his life at the end of the battle he was
undoubtedly one of the biggest
contributors in subduing the demon king
and if you're strong enough to hold the
ground against muzan you're definitely
deserving a place on our list in 16th
place is another hashida tengen uzue the
sound pillar even though we only got to
see him fighting in the entertainment
district arc he showed incredible skill
as he was fighting two upper moon demons
tengan has displayed incredible physical
feats of strength and speed being the
second physically strongest hashida in
the current generation as well as being
the fastest runner of all the hashida as
he was raised by shinobis and trained
ruthlessly to become a true shinobi
himself he had developed other great
qualities as well skills wise he could
match the combat proficiency of both
daki and gyotaro both of which are upper
ranked demons that have fought and
killed exactly 22 hashidas in the past
tengan was also able to effortlessly
decapitate daki without her even
realizing it impressively he was able to
fend off the combined efforts of daki
and gyotaro while being infected by a
poison that would kill someone instantly
under normal circumstances tengan has
also showcased great skill and precision
in using explosives minimizing damage
dealt to the surroundings and maximizing
the damage dealt to his opponents due to
his shinobi training tengens has great
technical skills and sharper senses
especially his sense of hearing which
helped him greatly during the course of
his battles even after losing his left
arm to gyutaro tengan was still able to
keep up with the upper ranks movements
further exemplifying his extraordinary
combat proficiency number 15 gyutaro as
the true upper rank 6 gyutaro is an
incredibly powerful demon with over a
century worth of combat experience under
his belt making him an extremely deadly
individual having killed a total of 15
hashida in the past his immense skills
and abilities were evident as he
possessed the means to easily combat
both tengen and tanjuro at the same time
even when the battle turned in the favor
of the demon slayers yutaro and daki
quickly managed to take control of the
situation and overwhelm them another
testament to his power is the fact that
despite being killed in battle yutaro
was still capable of severely injuring
and meimin tengen tanjiro and inosuke
and would have likely killed them if not
for his own arrogance getting the better
of him muzan kibutsuji later stated that
he regretted not letting yudaro fight
from the start and that if he did he
would probably be victorious against
demon slayers number 14 gyoko as the
holder of the fifth highest position in
the 12 kazuki gyoko is an extremely
powerful demon his unique blood demon
art and techniques allow him to easily
outclass the average demons and give him
the necessary edge to overwhelm and kill
even the most skilled and powerful
swordsmen in the demon slayer core as
upper rank 5 gyoko is more powerful than
gyutero and daki although we can't be
sure since we never saw them fight each
other in the case of the emergency yoko
can molt in and transform into his true
form boosting all his abilities and
liberating him from his vase allowing
him to move freely without needing to
teleport gyoko's true body is extremely
durable the upper rank remarked that the
scales that cover his body are harder
than diamonds furthermore whatever dyoko
touches is transmuted into fish making
him extremely dangerous to fight in
close range most notably in his duel
with muichiro gyoko was able to
overpower and hold the hashida back for
the majority of their fight even
managing to bring him to the brink of
death if not for gyoko's inherent
egotistical nature and muichiro
awakening his demon slayer mark the
upper rank would probably be able to
kill him number 13 tanjiro kamado
throughout the series tanjiro slowly
becomes more and more powerful with each
of his encounters and battles against
the demons even from the very beginning
of his training tanjido has always been
a sword fighting prodigy starting out
with skills rivaling sabito and avenging
his death by defeating the hand demon
despite being mizonotu ranked his skill
with the sword was superior to many of
his seniors he was able to go toe-to-toe
with many lower-ranked demons and defeat
them kanjido's first big transition in
power came when he was struggling to
inflict any damage on lower moon demon
rui he was then able to use a secret
technique called hinokami kagura a type
of sun breathing with this new power
tanjido could easily slice through rui's
threads and finally manage to injure him
after going through rehabilitation and
learning total concentration breeding
tangido became strong enough to stand on
equal ground against an upper moon demon
daki he was able to use hinokamikagura
again during the battle and was very
close to beheading the demon all by
himself even after being physically
exhausted from his fight against daki he
was able to assist tangent in his battle
against gyutero and later awakened his
demon slayer mark and beheaded the demon
tanjido was even able to defeat the
upper rank 3 akaza whom he had a great
hate for after akaza killed his friend
and hashida rengoku both he and yu
struggled against upper moon but in the
end kanjido was able to behead him after
accessing the transparent world and
selfless state after the fight tanjido
and gyu encountered the demon king
himself tangido managed to hold him off
despite losing one of his eyes and being
poisoned almost losing his life as a
result after muzan defeated all demon
slayers that were attacking him kanjido
was able to fight against him
single-handedly muzan expressed feelings
of unease towards tanjiro due to the
similarities between him and yorichi the
strongest demon slayer and swordsman to
ever exist with the help of obanai
tanjido managed to drive the demon king
into the corner and stall him until
sunrise putting an end to muzan once and
for all number 12 muichiro tokito
muichiro tokito often referred to as the
chosen one is missed hashira of the
demon slayer core and arguably the
member with the most development
potential as muichiro was the descendant
of the upper rank 1 kokushibo the former
demon slayer who used moon breathing
muichiro was born with special abilities
like him he joined the demon slayer
corps at a very young age by harsh
training and already present strength he
became a hashida in only two months
leaving everyone shocked he could easily
overpower demon slayers older than him
like tanjido inosuke and zenitsu after
awakening his demon slayer mark muichiro
is able to single-handedly defeat gyoko
upper rank 5 with relative ease even
after the upper rank assumed his true
form demonstrating just how powerful he
really was his technique was also
praised by kokushibu for being well
developed for one so young later on in
the fight his contributions proved to be
crucial in upper rank 1's defeat after
unlocking the transparent world and the
ability to turn his nietzsche and sword
into a bright red color moichiro was
able to land a critical blow on upper
rank 1 which played a pivotal role in
his defeat number 11. nakime nakime is
actually the first upper moon we see in
anime but at that time she was not
officially a member of the 12 kazuki she
was granted the title after form upper
rank 4 hantengu was killed by tanjiro
upon obtaining the rank and presumably
receiving more blood from muzan she
displayed the new ability to create and
detach several eyeballs from her body
this allowed her to spy on others from a
long range with this new ability she was
able to successfully find and locate the
positions of nearly all members of the
demon slayer corps as well as the hidden
mansion of kagaya ubuyashiki who had
gone to extreme lengths to hide its
location from even the highest ranking
members of the demon slayer corps
despite not displaying much in terms of
fighting ability as the holder of the
fourth highest position in the
organization nakime is an extremely
powerful demon she was capable of using
unorthodox blood demon art to deny the
efforts of obanai and mitsuri at
beheading her and stalled the two
hashida for most of the infinity castle
arc with neither of the two skilled
combatants being able to so much as
scratch her her signature ability was
the creation of the infinity castle
nakime's blood demon art takes the form
of an extra dimensional space that
houses a fortress of infinite scale as
the owner of this infinite fortress
nakime also possesses dominion over the
space being able to manipulate and alter
it at will by simply strumming her biwa
in her fortress there are countless
rooms with seemingly endless variety
like an open room filled with giant
pillars where the fight against
kokushibo took place a small garden
where the fight against doma took place
and a corridor leading to several other
rooms where the fight against akaza took
place nakime sits at the center of the
infinity castle with the entire space
being distorted around her with such a
unique ability we think that nakime
definitely deserves her position of
upper rank 4 and 11th place on our list
number 10 hantengu hantengu is the main
antagonist in the swordsmith village arc
and one of the most interesting demons
in the whole demon slayer world he has
seven different forms where each one is
spawned after the previous one is killed
as the holder of the fourth highest
title in the twelve kazuki hantengu is
one of the most powerful demons in the
series with his blood demon art he's
able to create four clones of himself
all of them possessing the same caliber
of strength as an upper ranked demon
these clones were able to hold off and
overwhelm the combined efforts of
tanjiro nezuko and genya genya stated
that hantengu was particularly difficult
to defeat as demon slayers would have to
play cat and mouse looking for the main
body while being chased down by four
upper ranked level demons as another
testament to his strength when the four
clones fused into one form zohakuten he
was once again capable of fending off
all three demon slayers as well as the
love hashida mitsuri even after the love
hashida awakened her demon slayer mark
she could only evade and dodge
zohakuten's attacks and stall until the
demon slayers defeated the main body
hantengu as zohakuten and tanjiro stated
mitsuri would have run out of stamina
and died if not for the sun rising and
hantengu being killed number 9 kyojiro
rengoku when it comes to hashida's
kyojiro is one of the fan favorites
apart from his goofy personality he's
extremely dedicated to his job and has
slain many demons while being flame
hashira he became a hashida by
single-handedly defeating lower rank ii
haido who even appraised his
swordsmanship before he died moreover
his father the previous flame hashida
stated that after he stopped teaching
his son kiyojiro trained himself by
learning from the guidebook of the flame
breeding style a book which only had
three volumes one of rengoku's greatest
abilities was his extra sensory
perception as seen when he was capable
of sensing demonic presences faster and
more accurately than tanjido he detected
two demons on the train before anyone
else did kyojiro was also able to
perceive tanjiro's injuries and torn
blood vessels accurately which allowed
him to teach the boy how to stop the
bleeding preventing him from dying as
another testament to his strength even
the fourth most powerful demon of all
time akaza acknowledged kyojito's
strength he even went as far as to offer
to turn kyojiro into a demon so he could
surpass his human limits and become
stronger something he only offered to
swordsmen whose abilities were trained
to their absolute limits akaza also
complemented his battle spirit and
stated that it's getting close to the
realm of the highest which implied that
he was incredibly close to obtaining the
transparent world and the selfless state
even though rengoku died in his battle
against akaza he showed just how strong
he really is and was almost able to kill
upper rank three all by himself number
eight you tomiyoka gyu is the first
hashida we got to see in anime is the
current water hashira and the main
reason for tanjido's joining the demon
slayer corps as he was the one to send
him to trainer sakonji during his fight
against akaza upper moon said himself
that giu is the strongest demon slayer
that he has fought in a long time
because of this fact we had to put him
higher on the list than rengoku from the
beginning giu showed just how powerful
hashidas truly are he was able to easily
defeat the father spider demon in his
transformed state and rui lower rank
five something tangible and inosuki
failed to accomplish gyu was also shown
easily beating dozens of demons equal to
that of the lower ranks of the 12th
kazuki during his fight against akaza he
was able to hold his own the demon was
amazed by gyu's skills to the point
where that he offered to transform the
hashida into a demon the same proposal
he made to ringoku when he first
awakened his mark view was able to
momentarily overpower akaza repeatedly
cutting his arms slicing his body and
even cutting his neck when he
encountered the demon king muzan eu was
able to hold him off for a decent amount
of time along with tanjido and later
played a pivotal role in his defeat
moreover after tanjiro became a demon eu
was the first to act and fend him off
defending zenitsu and akakushi while
fighting evenly with him long enough for
him to be turned back to a human the
seventh character on our list is sanemi
the wind pillar we can't be sure if he
is actually stronger than gu because in
a sparring match both pillars were able
to hold their own it is sanami's wind
breathing and its attacking
characteristics that made us rank him
higher than giu sanomi has displayed his
extraordinary abilities and proficiency
in combat on multiple occasions in the
infinity castle arc sonomy was shown to
be capable of annihilating dozens of
demons comparable to lower ranked demons
and later could hold his own against
upper rank 1 kokushibu according to
kokushibo sanemi's physical abilities
and techniques have reached their
absolute maximum kokushibu also
commented that sanomi and gyome were
highly skilled even among the ranks of
the hashida one of his signature
abilities is actually his own blood
sanomi's blood was revealed to be one of
the rarest blood types making it
incredibly intoxicating to demons it's
also unique due to its intense potency
even the smallest width of his blood
immediately causes demons to salivate
and lose focus as his blood was able to
affect even the strongest of the upper
ranks kokushibo however its effects
waned after a while and was proven to be
completely ineffective against muzan
despite his blood's potency nezuko was
shown to be able to resist it due to her
own strong conviction and will he is
also thought to be a hashida with the
best stamina his incredible stamina and
pain endurance also shone through during
his battle with kokushibo where he could
keep up with the upper ring demon for an
extended period of time by himself
without the demon slayer mark and upon
receiving numerous severe injuries from
one of kokoshibu's techniques still
continued to fight which left demons in
shock number six akaza when it comes to
demons and their backstories akasa
surely has a unique one as a child
without martial arts training akaza
could defeat and knock grown men
unconscious on his own at the age of 18
after learning the martial arts from
kaizo he was capable of single-handedly
annihilating 67 trained adult swordsmen
with his bare fists a feat which even
muzen couldn't believe was performed by
a mere human even after muzan
transformed him into a demon he
continued fighting barehanded as the
holder of the third highest position in
the 12 kazuki akaza is an extremely
powerful demon and combatant having been
able to defeat rengoku and numerous
hashida as well as countless demon
slayers in the past akaza possesses
incredible abilities and attributes most
notably his martial arts prowess which
can outmatch the swordsmanship of even
the most skilled demon slayers and his
ability to sense fighting spirit which
allows him to predict his opponent's
attacks and discern their weaknesses
making him highly unbeatable during the
infinity castle arc he was able to fight
and overwhelm both tangido and giu
during their fight despite them both
being hashida level swordsman with the
demon slayer marks akasad was only
defeated when tanjido awakened the
selfless state which directly countered
his extra-sensory perception even after
being decapitated akazan managed to
regrow his head through sheer willpower
and his extraordinary regenerative
abilities if akazad didn't lose his will
to continue fighting he would have
certainly killed both demon slayers as
he had already rendered them extremely
fatigued number 5 doma as the holder of
upper rank 2 doma is the second highest
ranking member in the 12 kazuki and the
third strongest demon in existence his
combination of combat skill and his
powerful cryokinetic blood demon art in
battle is powerful enough to overwhelm
and defeat the insect hashida shinobu
without any difficulty and he also noted
to have defeated kane kocho the late
flower hashira in the past doma was also
able to take out inosuke and kanau who
were on par with the hashidas
simultaneously without much effort
either according to doma akaza who holds
the rank of upper 3 would have no chance
of defeating him in battle as further
credence to doma's immense power he
rarely fights seriously and instead
adopts a casual and carefree attitude
even in life and death situations
against the most powerful demon slayers
only ever becoming serious when his life
is in serious danger such as when the
deadly effects of shinobu's poisons
became apparent his cryokinesis blood
demon art is what actually makes him
upper rank too he can generate ice and
frost from his flesh and blood and can
spawn it anywhere in his vicinity as
well as manipulating it at will allowing
him to unleash incredibly potent ice
techniques additionally the ice created
from his blood demon art is extremely
lethal to those that inhale it causing
the cells of the victim's lungs to die
and rendering them unable to breathe
normally his ice has also been noted to
be extremely cold as shown when the air
around doma's ice was cold enough to
make shinobu's lungs feel as if they
were about to burst and nearly freeze
kanawha's body and surroundings just by
coming into contact with it even though
doma was defeated in the end we think
that if he took the fight more seriously
from the start he would definitely be
able to kill all three of his opponents
number four giome himejima gyome is the
stone pillar and one of the strongest
humans to ever live he is stated by both
tanjido and inosuke to be the strongest
demon slayer in the entire organization
as remarked by tengen uzui guiome
climbed to the rank of a hashida in a
mere two months this is further given
credence by kokushimo who noted that
guillemet's physical abilities have been
trained to their absolute maximum and
also stated that in the last 300 years
he's not encountered a warrior as strong
as guillemet he was able to put up a
fight against the strongest upper rank
without the use of his demon slayer mark
further showing the extent of his skill
later during his battle he revealed that
he too had awakened his mark appearing
as cracked earth fissure-like patterns
on both of his forearms when activated
it drastically increases his physical
abilities such as his strength speed and
stamina allowing him to fight the upper
rank for an extended period of time due
to being blind guillemet has compensated
and alternated his senses to adapt to
his condition effectively developing a
superhuman sense of hearing his sense of
hearing was so acute that gilman could
accurately discern and interact with his
surroundings normally even engaging in
high speed combat with demons without
trouble guillemet uses the sound of his
change rattling to tell the exact
position the chain is in and he uses
that to guide his axe and flail during
combat after the fight against kokoshibo
geome who was injured and slightly
fatigued was able to contribute to
driving muzan into a corner gyome is
definitely the strongest out of all the
hashidas in the demon slayer core and
that's why he's ranked so high on this
list number three kokushibo kokushibu
formerly known as michikatsu tsukikuni
is the brother of yorichitsukuni the
original creator of breathing styles
jealousy and hate towards his brother
led him to accept muzan's offer to
become a demon believing that he will
become stronger than his brother and
that he will never die kokoshibo was an
extraordinarily powerful demon proven to
be the strongest of the 12 kazuki and
the second strongest demon in existence
just behind the demon king muzan
kibutsuji himself as one of the oldest
demons in the series he had battled
numerous demon slayers and obtained vast
experience and knowledge of combat he
was able to easily decipher the
techniques and skills of the hashidas
and overwhelm them in battle his
physique is one of the most polished and
immense in the existence as not only is
he a user of total concentration
breathing but also a marked individual
as well as a member of the 12 kazuki who
possesses the highest concentration of
muzan's blood he created his own
breathing style moon breathing but is
still to this day one of the most
powerful breaths in the world these
overall abilities and skills allowed
kokushibu to defeat to hashira with
minimal effort and then fight against
both sanemi and gyome the latter of
which was considered to be the most
powerful among hashidas even when
guillemet and sanemi awakened their
demon slayer marks which increased their
physical abilities way above their
normal limits he was still capable of
holding his own against both of them
simultaneously as a testament to his
might it ultimately took a combo of
attacks from guillaume sanemimuichiro
and genya all of which who were
exceptionally strong individuals to even
land a significant injury on him he was
so strong the only way that the demon
slayers had a chance at winning was to
immobilize him which took the lives of
muichiro and genya the latter needing to
use a blood demon arc in order to do so
meaning that normal attacks wouldn't
work against kokushibo at all toward the
end of their fight he even acquired the
ability to regenerate his severed head
leaving the sun as his only weakness
ultimately kokoshibu's loss was mostly a
result of his resolve wavering upon
realizing that his lust for power had
turned him into a monster causing him to
stop regenerating rather than the skills
of his opponents finally the next one on
our list is demon lord himself muzak
kibutsuji before we start with
explaining muzan's powers we think that
muzan should share this place with
tanjido's demon king form although we
only see this form of tangido briefly
near the end of the manga it's clear
that his strength was outstanding we
don't want to make a separate entry for
this form since there isn't enough
information about it so if you wondered
where we put it it's the second place
now let's go back to explaining muzan as
the first demon to exist and as the
progenitor of all demons muzan is the
strongest demon in existence and
possesses tremendous power and
attributes far superior to all of the 12
kazuki after consuming the blue spider
lily muzan developed supernatural blood
with special properties that can
transform humans into demons once
ingested his special blood also seems to
give rise to a plethora of special
abilities unique to demons such as
powerful regeneration the power to shape
shift immortality an accelerated growth
rate enhanced physical prowess and even
supernatural abilities called blood
demon arts muzan can control demons he
created to a certain extent as seen when
he was able to take control of nakeme's
body in order to try to force absorption
of yushido's cells in order to stop his
interference when he attempted to use
sir power of the infinity castle during
the course of the series we could see
muzan in many forms but his combat form
is where his power really lays in this
form he's strong enough to create
massive craters in the ground or destroy
entire chunks of buildings the sharp two
jaws located all over his body in this
form not only serve as his main form of
offense in battle but also have the
purpose of helping him recover faster
since he could use the jaws to tear
apart his opponents and eat their flesh
his immense abilities were best
displayed when he was able to hold his
own against five hashidas he was later
able to put tanjido in a state of near
death in a single attack and would have
nearly killed mitsuri had she not been
rescued by fellow demon slayers geomet
yu sunemi and obanai would have also
succumbed to his poison and died if they
didn't receive antidotes after
approximately 30 minutes of fighting
against the hashida muzan manifested leg
whips which increased his attack speed
exponentially to a point where he
instantly defeated the exhausted demon
slayers however it was later revealed
that muzan was gradually becoming slower
due to tamayo's aging medicine which has
been affecting him for the entirety of
the battle despite this he was still
able to easily defeat the demon slayers
and hold the advantage over tanjido who
mastered sun breathing although muzan
was a demon lord with seemingly infinite
power there's one character who is even
stronger than him and that's none other
than yorichitsugikuni who takes a top
spot on our list yorichi is the
strongest known demon slayer in history
being born with the demon slayer mark
transparent world and selfless state as
well as possessing a godlike physique
and innate swordsmanship talent as a
child who has never picked up a sword
before he was able to defeat a trained
sword instructor effortlessly and he was
referred to as a miraculous prodigy
beyond compare after training as a demon
slayer yorichi could defeat multiple
demons to where his older brother stated
that he as a child couldn't even compare
to him as an adult he alone was able to
corner muzan kibutsuji and overpowered
him in an instant and handed him on the
verge of death until he managed to
escape despite having avoided death
muzen was deeply scarred by that
encounter referring to him as a monster
and even the side of his earrings made
him tremble in shock and the mere
memories of yorichi caused the bodies of
other demons who have never met him to
tremble shortly before his death of at
least 85 years in age he'd battled his
older twin brother kokoshibo who turned
into a demon despite both his old age
and apparent blindness he quickly gained
the upper hand in the battle with a
single move sillating his throat before
he finally died standing up unscathed
kokoshibu himself admits that if yorici
launched a second swing before dying he
would have killed him while commenting
yorichi's power was still in his prime
yorichi's strength is not even
comparable to anyone else in the entire
story he was the first breathing style
user and the only one who got muzan to
his knees therefore he is deserving of
first place on our list click on this
video where we explained all breathing
styles in demon's lair